[Música]
[Aplausos]
villas
la vida en un mundo aparte
madres solas remando contra un mar de
piedra
una cultura del padre ausente del padre
de preso del padre acribillado
del padre presente
pero con la espalda disecada
[Música]
los cascotes que inventan caminos
así el barro no te muerde los tobillos
esqueletos de autos robados y prendidos
fuego
charlas de vecinas a través del
alambrado mientras cuelgan la ropa en la
soga
la policía y sus cacerías entre
carcajadas espumantes
policías parientes de su objetivo
el comedor y su pálida merienda entre
una pesadumbre coloreada
los que se van a trabajar con sus
bolsillos sus bicis y sus ojos cansados
madres que lloran la muerte dijo chorros
en velorios propios y ajenos
los evangelistas y sus gritos de mentira
los perros persiguiendo a las motos
el guiso salvador del mediodía
él mismo hizo a la noche
lo que quede de ese guiso mañana
el micro que recorre las cárceles
desbordado de familiares
la cumbia poniéndole ritmo a la miseria
el amanecer y los carros
el amanecer y los que todavía siguen de
gira
muchos sueldos flacos destinados a
disfrazar la pobreza
maradona que mató la policía
que son obreros
que derrochan su magia pero en una
canchita de barro y llena de vidrios
la avenida es una frontera que divide a
la villa del mundo
por eso los restos ofrendan hasta con
sangre por el milagro de exiliarse hacia
afuera
sinfonía de la lluvia maltratando a las
chapas
extranjeros de la clase media que vienen
a comprar droga y que se van descalzos y
llorando
velas derritiéndose en los mini
santuarios con la foto de los pibes que
murieron
paredes que recuerdan sus hazañas
las esquinas sonrientes con los guachos
y las pibas salpicando chispas cósmicas
niños que se convierten en padres
habitantes que se conocen todos secretos
que saben todos
engaños imposibles de ocultar
donde vive la clase sin clase la única
dueña de todas las escobas
donde nos llegan los premios de la
meritocracia
donde el horizonte siempre tiene olor a
celda tiene olor a bala tiene olor a
trabajo precario tiene olor a traje
encargado de limpieza
es la villa es otro mundo es vivir
apartado
[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchas gracias
césar cuando cómo y para qué escribiste
este poema bueno este poema fue escrito
hace casi diez años más o menos yo tenía
19 en ese entonces estaba preso en el
penal de marcos paz tuve cinco años
presos y bueno fue una forma de salir a
dar una vuelta por mi barrio sin tener
que moverme porque tampoco podía no
obviamente y fue una forma de recrear la
experiencia a partir del recuerdo con la
imaginación no dar esa vuelta por el
barrio de forma imaginaria pero no
simplemente dar una vuelta por el barrio
y de escribir no me interesaba
simplemente de escribir sino agregarle a
esa descripción un filtro que es el
filtro de mi concepción de cómo es vivir
en la villa para mucha gente
no se vive como la vivo yo no con las
palabras que le pongo yo a la vida en la
villa así que fueron filtros filosóficos
políticos ideológicos de cosas que pasan
para mí en la villa que son injustas que
no deberían pasar es decir no romantizar
la vida en la villa pero también bueno
rescatar toda la belleza que surge en
medio de tanta muerte no bueno ustedes
al gonzález señores muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y